[Music]
I know you worked hard on the Pretty
Little Liars spin-off yes what can you
tell us about that oh my gosh that was
everything about it was just so surreal
such a dream so honored to be a part of
it to work with Marlene King such a
female centered story which I love so
much so there are tons of Secrets as you
can imagine that I can't tell you about
yeah can you tease a secret
I can't just that there are secrets
that's all I can say could you give us a
few words to describe the show fans are
just like solid absolutely it is
dramatic it's dark it's a serious it's
romantic and full of secrets as the PLL
world goes how do you think it's
different from Peola you know it's a
whole new path to whole new storyline it
has you know definitely inspiration from
PLL as well as Alison and Mona which is
so cool but it's exfoli world like what
will the fans who loves PLL so much how
how will they feel connected to
definitely make the characters of Mona
and Alison the secrets the lies and
there's a sensation of constantly being
watched as well like there was in PLO so
there's like the same essence of a story
how do you think they'll react I'm
hoping they'll love it the reaction has
been so amazing so far it was so
overwhelming once it was announced I was
fast so I hope they love it as much as
we do we're pouring our hearts into it
so we're really excited so will we see
any other original cast members involved
in some way we'd heard like Troy in my
track I've heard Troy and I heard
jeez so hopefully they'll be they'll be
involved as much as they would look like
she will have them on the show behind us
hopefully both
[Music]